[Music]
hi welcome to JK news so Nikki oh shoot
I just took the button for fine in
mansplaining news submitted by East LA
all day a three-day conference for women
led by men hopes to make women great
again by men yeah to make to help ladies
be a lady finally understand how the
world works great again what does that
mean be great ago you guys used to be
really good well like back in the like
when the feminist movement or back
before then when I know what he's
talking about there actually
anti-feminist what go on okay so this is
happening in Orlando Florida
okay it's a convention where women buy
tickets to get man's flamed by dudes who
want to help them become gravy is that
specifically the pitch they want to be
mansplain like hey come here so you
could be man slain yes absolutely well
and it's basically like is this a joke I
think that there's an element of Troy
yeah passive aggressive what actually
okay for example here's a direct quote
no longer will you have to give in to
toxic bullying the toxic bullying
feminist dogma and go against your
biological nature right isn't that some
inherently [ __ ] made [ __ ] Oh candy it
certainly can be well that you watch the
guys are like trying so hard to prove
what a man they are but in doing so they
end up acting like a little [ __ ] and
yelling at women this convention started
that way
what's a club is a make women getting a
comfort its the 21 convention 21
convention right 22 conventions the 21
convention is a convention for men to
learn how to be men oh oh so they're
just saying the [ __ ] kind of yeah that's
the difference of wait what's 22
convention the name of it yeah the name
of this
Oh what do you want is for men I think
that's really [ __ ] important actually
is a manuscript of becoming a man or
just so much human what is it man
there's no definition
the other one is taught by women - men
yes Oh taught by men - men as the
government and this one is men to men to
women so there's no women teachers I
wouldn't want to see a seminar of a
woman teaching a man how to be a man
that would be very interesting woman's
image of what a man is it's completely
different sometimes from what a man's
image of what a man is right yeah yeah
so that's that's exactly their whole
point with the with the 22 invention is
don't you want to hear from us as men
what we want in a woman come and join
this big titties nice legs
yes no yep nice file I mean it would be
only tight [ __ ] women teaching men how
to be men and the other that would make
sense right that would be like cuz the
other ones taught by men - so there are
they trolling against those men like I
don't know okay cuz I mean I way if I
was a guy at the other one I would want
to know what's gonna get me laid so I'd
want a woman to teach me like what like
what they want in a man no look I what
exactly is mansplaining - what is that
it's like when I tell Geo why as a woman
she's angry or some [ __ ] yeah like
you're telling females about female
problems yeah you know the reason why
you're angry is because you're on your
period and then guys have no idea
because they don't go through up yeah
you have no idea what the hormones are
but we're still trying to put what the
guy is thinking into yes Wayne but it
even it even goes into like a woman like
astronaut is being explained about
science by some guy that knows nothing
about science like or like a guy is
explaining to this woman astronaut how
the [ __ ] is that the target you are like
why why is that man display that's just
the idiot be another male astronaut
explaining science to another female
astronaut for no reason like as if she
doesn't know it's because she's I think
that oh yeah like he just automatically
assumes just because she's a woman she
doesn't not even without this yeah
exactly yeah
what's the red pill stuff the red pill
is a group of in cells I heard of that
yeah I went out there who think that
women there's a way that you could talk
to women and it'll make them more
sexually attracted to you
don't they also think that all women are
gold diggers yes they think women are
gold-digging [ __ ] they're not that
anymore what is this not well no there's
a lot of those for sure update me on the
status of how women are the guy who
created this convention thing he also
has a I forgot what it's called but I
think it's like the Redman group or
something which is like stemming from
the red pill I thought it was the
offshoot of guy that painted selves red
and they started playing with bucket
bucket drums and [ __ ] they're not that
smart they should have come up with that
so the 21 convention from what I've read
seems to be more catered to like the
Intel community kind of thing yes so
these same guys are the ones doing the
22 convention so in cells teaching women
what they're supposed to be in cells
teaching whim open-minded women are are
buying the picture shut up [ __ ] off
so in their and their minds and their
perspective from what I have in the
mindset of an in cell the guys the
organizers I'm just gonna say that they
view this as this is a perfect
opportunity to teach women what we want
right like what I said before
and so in their heads they want like the
1950's type of woman Y very like we see
in the kitchen
and submit them yeah we we pump out
babies I'm getting mixed signals from
this and this is what I have had a
problem I'm asked
I've tried to ask you to try to
understand like this community of people
because they don't want their women to
be gold diggers so then wouldn't you
want a woman with a job in a career that
makes her own money but no they want a
woman to stay at home in the kitchen but
then she'd have to use your money so
then it makes her a gold digger what the
[ __ ] do you want do you want a woman
that makes money or wants your money you
can't I don't want a woman that gets mad
like yeah
I'm trying to understand your part
though maybe I need a ticket to this
glitch assuming me and I don't like it
they'll beat it that's funny
a woman should not should be seen and
not heard but yeah yeah pretty much
that's a bomb I think maybe for them
their thought processes while I'm
controlling the money I get to see where
the money's going here I'm not giving
you like I'll give you the allowance and
it's I have all the country to suck my
dick I'll give you some money maybe
what's the benefit for the girl and she
gets to be with him but she isn't gonna
pick the things good spot no yeah it's
that she gets to be she gets to cook
yeah oh she gets to cook and suck his
dick finally whoa guys it's clear to me
know okay got it bigger thing I think
they view that I was like oh they don't
want me to be like to be with they don't
want to be with me because I'm such a
king they want to be with me only
because of this this [ __ ] this money
pile that I have yeah so they view
themselves like their God how [ __ ] up
of so this is this phenomenon that's
coming out I think it's like from the
high divorce rates from our parents
generation going on - like recent like
so we have shitty images of the family
structure and just how couples are
because we don't have good role models
right about that right so like if you
think about this whole thing right we
grow up with kind of a [ __ ] up image
of what the other gender is supposed to
be or how we're supposed to be as men or
whatever don't there's no real rule out
there or what the structure is so now
you have females growing up with maybe a
[ __ ] up view of men because their
personal experience with the broken home
and whatever and vice versa the same
thing with men maybe you know in most
cases if you're comfortable broken home
you you're fatherless right so you don't
know how to be what a man is you just
kind of back in the day there was a lot
of women that stayed in abusive
relationships it couldn't make money
outside of the relation but that's not
the norm
abusive relationships you know like that
is the extreme like the norm was a
regular family staying together and and
and it's not people [ __ ] like
seem like little kids getting married
but that's not the nor do you know like
people didn't grow up with the parents
[ __ ] beating each other up all day
long like this is this image that we
have of how it used to be like
controlling and [ __ ] up in all that
I'm just saying the women don't really
have a lot of options like they had to
stay in the relationship because they
couldn't go to college and get a job or
any of that
like we wait way back in like this okay
going back to role models right so like
if you if you had a model human being
like and and and let's say like the mom
did the traditional thing of like
raising the kids right making a good
home and then you had the traditional
father who brought home the bread or
whatever and he was responsible and he
taught the kids discipline or whatever
right these roles were clearly defined
now let's say the majority is a broken
home let's say that you know there's an
absent father or whatever right like if
that's the norm right that's a [ __ ] up
role model true so we don't have a good
upbringing because we don't have a way
of how do you become an adult how do you
live in a loving relationship and I
guess that's the point that I'm trying
to say is that if that's the majority
maybe back then was better because at
least it was a manuscript of what you're
some you're just talking about child
rearing though you're like a lot of
people are gonna are going to take what
you're saying conflate it into you
saying that it was better back in the
50s and [ __ ] but I know exactly right
right can't play devil's advocate sure
um so I grew up in a marriage of
household like my parents are still
married my dad would constantly like
since he paid for everything paid for my
mom worked too but I'm saying like to me
my dad's relationship to me was I pay
for everything so you can't question me
so sometimes we get into arguments where
he was very wrong like he'd accused me
of like losing something and then but
that's an unhealthy relationship but so
my motivation as a child was like I'm
gonna make my own money as soon as I get
out of here but if that wasn't an option
for me if my only option for life was
I'm gonna be a housewife to some other
guy who's gonna control everything I
think I'd be depressed is for you and
I'm not again
and I don't know who is really I don't
know if that's the case here but that's
a marriage right but my argument is just
having good role models and good human
beings which we don't have so that's why
this kind of [ __ ] pops out is because
there is no way to be an adult like how
do we [ __ ] do this [ __ ] I don't give
a [ __ ] if the woman's the bread winner
or the guy is it's just we need to have
[ __ ] human beings that are looted in
a loving relationship whether you're gay
or straight or whatever [ __ ] earning
yeah does it matter if it doesn't matter
if the guys cooking other girls cook you
know who's making money but you just
need role models that you see teamwork
you see them achieve see teamwork okay
yeah fight through struggle and people
and little kids can see ok cool two
people working together regardless of
which gender does what I probably didn't
explain this right but here here here's
this here's what I'm saying why they're
reverting back to the good old days is
because the good old days had a man
distinct that it's even better than what
we have now which is uncertainty and we
don't know where to go well there's a
lot a lot of loosey-goosey [ __ ] to that
I'm not even saying these guys are
talking about where it's like I'm gonna
raise my I seen this with some of my
friends it's like I'm gonna raise my son
to play with Barbies I'm gonna raise my
daughter to play with [ __ ] GI Joes
and purposely be counterculture but it's
like dude it's just let them like what
whatever they play with this whole idea
of like I'm gonna force this on them
it's [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
and so you ejecting political views into
your the way you raise your kids yeah
it's just as like bad is the other way
around you could only play with Barbies
you can only play with and it's just as
bad as like I walked in on my son he was
painting his nails this morning he's
three holy [ __ ]
and going over through the [ __ ]
genius at three it's pretty good thirty
right there but you know what I'm saying
like works were a man what might maybe
wouldn't previously freak the [ __ ] out
about that and go off the handle for no
reason you know I'm saying or like I
walked into my son was wearing a dress
that his sister had holy [ __ ] what is
happening how did we [ __ ] this up you
know like like that it's the same exact
idea it's just on the other side yeah so
speakers include founder Anthony dream
Johnson who bills himself as the first
president of the manosphere that's a
pretty good nickname analyst Alexander J
a Cortez a fitness guru who famously
enraged the internet by tweeting out a
list detailing how to be a beautiful
woman more pink shaving and being thin
what Joe's good intentions were it's
[ __ ] job I mean dude but it's stefan
molyneux is one and then this writer
named mike Serna vich who has a lisp and
he argues that there's no such thing as
rape but i think it was a joke
I think it was a joke I don't know I
don't know for sure yeah yeah he's uh
he's a pretty high-level contender
Walter where no see what did he do he's
like heaven think you like the front man
of the thing what see I think dumb
people fall for like yeah I mean they're
all trying to make sense of this whole
cultural phenomenon that we're going
through right now which is redefining
gender and what does that mean uh just
the final question uh how many tickets
have they sold I don't know I don't know
can we make money from this right but
it's two G's for a ticket no but right
now it's half off so it's a thousand
that's dope what kind of money yeah
[ __ ] and honestly they're they're
loving this cuz they're getting nothing
but publicity and that's what trolling
is all about at the end of the day
that's why I mean come on the nobody'd
even be talking about this if it wasn't
for I think it's funny though so do you
think you think they're trawling you
don't get too serious I hope I think
some people take it seriously the people
paying ping twelve thousand dollars a
ticket I think the women would be the
people paying for the tickets yeah but
there's some women in comments that are
like that's how it should be you know
the woman should stay at home and like
we should be staying at home and like
that's what our world we should I also
don't think that's wrong either
exactly right could be right that is
different that's a whole different I
think everyone should choose exactly
what they wanted
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]